well America of course is gradually
demographically moving to the left it's
becoming more humane these are these
simple Republican slogans spend and grow
spending grog you know drill drill your
way into trouble all this sort of stuff
these daft cliches are not holding up
even in Middle America which is a
bastion of conservatism based on the way
America was made during the 19th century
of course and I think that America will
move towards the the true deepening idea
of making a society where nobody gets
left behind this is going to be a big
project and we've had this before we've
had it with LBJ and so on and sign the
Civil Rights Act but this is now going
to be a deepening movement and we are
going to be spending more on
infrastructure because we have the
available workforce because we have a
bad economy and I think it's it's the
inside of things that will get fixed not
the outward appearance of things and I
don't think it's going to be spectacular
in its outwardness but it's going to
have a lot more integrity to it and
America is moving towards a kind of
maturity and these slights that are
sometimes hurled Europe like Old Europe
will be significantly Lessing in
currency
I wouldn't say I was proud to be an
American I'm proud to be an artist and I
I love America there are there are many
things in America that are great but I
don't like this I'm proud to be an
American business you know this flag
waving business I think this is a really
bad scene and it's at poisoning the
international family of human beings I'm
proud to be an American I'm proud to be
Irish you should be proud to be a human
being and and to be able to interact and
have love and consideration for other
human beings you might as well say I'm
proud to be a flag
well I'm optimistic but that's a
question of nature and also I don't
really see much point in being
pessimistic if if I'm wrong if things
don't work out if we're not able to make
the world better and won't matter will
it be cuz we'll all be dead so I do
think that as Stephen Hawking says the
next 200 years is going to be very
important we have to evolve in our
understanding of ourselves and we have
to move away with another reference to
the flag from tribalism towards
globalism we have no choice but we have
to manage our planet and we have to
manage that planet or out of the planets
around us in our spatial environment and
because we will colonize space if we are
around